Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件现在正在发生令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造为你带来收入的被动收益，而不是不断用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“冲刺经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都对你适用。此外，还有由丽莎亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接参加挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一辅导一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有细节发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你想成为一名心理学家，就让这成为你的指南。节目。嘉宾：玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）嗨，欢迎来到“有志心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. So what I love about doing the role that I do in supporting aspiring psychologists is the truly random and wide breadth of different expertise and experiences that you guys have as listeners. And today's podcast is a guest podcast episode with someone I've connected with on LinkedIn. And they are at a much earlier stage of their psychology career and had wanted to ask me some questions. And I said, you know what, this would make a really good podcast episode because other people will likely want to know the answer to your questions too. So would you be up for coming on and asking me on the session so the answer was yes thankfully um and yeah we had a slight glitch um with the wi-fi um for our guest today and so I'm on camera
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。我所做的工作中，最让我喜欢的是支持有志成为心理学家的人，作为听众，你们拥有真正随机且极其广泛的不同专业知识和经验。今天的播客是一期嘉宾访谈节目，嘉宾是我在领英（LinkedIn）上结识的一位朋友。他的心理学职业生涯还处于非常早期的阶段，并想向我提一些问题。我说，你知道吗，这会是一期非常棒的播客节目，因为其他人很可能也想知道你这些问题的答案。所以你愿意上节目来问我这些问题吗？谢天谢地，答案是肯定的。嗯，是的，我们今天的嘉宾在Wi-Fi上遇到了一点小故障，所以我现在是开着视频的。
um but the lovely Ben um we've got we've got a photo but yeah if you're wanting to to watch on YouTube please do come along it's Dr Marianne Trent and whilst you're there to watch on YouTube, please do come along. It's Dr. Marianne Trent. And whilst you're there, click a few likes, make a few comments, and, yeah, get chatty in the comments because that's always really nice to see. You can also, if you're not a fan of listening to podcasts, you can also access the back catalogue of these podcast episodes as blog articles too. To do that you go to www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash blog. I hope you find this episode really useful and I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi, welcome along to Ben Munro who's joining us for today's podcast episode. Hi.
嗯，不过可爱的本（Ben），我们有一张照片，但是，如果你想在YouTube上观看，请务必来收看，频道是Dr. Marianne Trent。在你观看YouTube的同时，也请点赞、留言，并且在评论区热烈讨论，因为看到这些总是让人非常开心。如果你不太喜欢听播客，你也可以将这些播客节目的往期内容作为博客文章来阅读。要做到这一点，你可以访问 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk 斜杠 blog。希望你会觉得这一期节目非常有用，我期待在节目的另一端与你交流。嗨，欢迎今天加入我们播客节目的本·芒罗（Ben Munro）。嗨。
Thank you so much. And this episode is going to be a little bit different to usual. So for those of you who have listened to episodes before, you might well have heard me say that I'm a big fan of LinkedIn. And I think Ben was like, well, I'm taking her for a word and I'm going to connect with her. And, yeah, we got chatting in the DMs on LinkedIn. well I'm taking I'm taking her for her word and I'm gonna I'm gonna connect with her and um yeah we got chatting um in the DMs on LinkedIn and I was like Ben do you fancy coming on and being a guest on the podcast and you were like ah okay so um to give a bit of context, Ben is a little earlier in his career than most people, well, all people we've had on the podcast so far, which I think is really, really exciting and shows us what a diverse group of people we are reaching with this podcast.
非常感谢。这一期节目将与以往有点不同。所以对于那些听过之前节目的听众，你们很可能听我说过我是领英（LinkedIn）的超级粉丝。我想本当时想的可能是，好吧，我要听她的话，去跟她建立联系。然后，我们在领英的私信里聊了起来。好吧，我要听取她的话，去跟她建立联系，然后，我们在领英的私信里聊了聊，我说：“本，你想不想上播客当一次嘉宾？”你当时反应是“啊，好的……”所以，为了提供一些背景信息，本的职业生涯比我们播客迄今为止邀请过的绝大多数人、或者说所有人都要更早一些，我觉得这真的非常非常令人兴奋，也向我们展示了通过这个播客，我们接触到了多么多元化的一群人。
So Ben has told me that he is in his first year of A-levels at college. Is that right, Ben? Yeah, yeah. Brilliant. So it's exciting. I, you know, it's bringing back all sorts of memories when I was doing my A-level psychology. Yeah, exciting times, exciting times.
所以本告诉我，他现在在大学读A-Level的第一年。是这样的吗，本？是的，是的。太棒了。所以这很令人兴奋。这让我想起了我当年读A-Level心理学时的各种回忆。是的，令人兴奋的时光，令人兴奋的时光。
How are you finding it? It's good, yeah. It's definitely much better than secondary school, sort of a new independence and stuff uh it's great and obviously i'm studying psychology biology and maths and they're all that's like some of my three favorite subjects at gcc it's going real well yeah oh good so we had a little bit of crossover there so i did biology and psychology i thought about maths but my favourite maths teacher wasn't doing the A level syllabus and I was like well no I think I only got my A in maths because of my favourite
你觉得感觉怎么样？挺好的，是的。绝对比中学好得多，有一种全新的独立性之类的，感觉很棒。而且很显然，我在学心理学、生物学和数学，这些都是我在GCSE时最喜欢的几门科目，现在进展得很顺利，是的。哦，太好了。所以我们俩有一点交集，我当时选了生物和心理学。我想过选数学，但由于我最喜欢的数学老师不教A-Level的教学大纲，我就想，好吧，我觉得我数学能拿A完全是因为我最喜欢的
maths teacher so I'm going to give that a side swerve oh and you did psychology GCSE you said as well yeah I did yeah yeah yeah it's still quite um like nobody who I know who I didn't go to my school does it so it's quite rare around where I'm from but yeah it's uh it's definitely different today a lot less what's less essays and stuff yeah so what's the dream where do you hope to get to what do you want to do when you're I was gonna say when you're when you're all grown up when you're a proper grown-up but frankly I still don't feel like a proper grown-up so what do you hope will be in your future career um a decline qualification i guess at the end of the day um but i want to be able to help people is the end goal i guess no matter sort of what it ends up being just helping people in general brilliant well I think
数学老师，所以我就放弃了。哦，你还说过你考过心理学GCSE，对吧？是的，考过，是的。它仍然相当……我认识的人里面没有一个去我的学校的人学这个，所以在我老家周围这相当罕见。但它确实……它和今天很不同，论文之类的作业要少得多。所以，你的梦想是什么？你希望去到哪里？当你……我本来想说当你真正长大成人时，当你成为一个成熟的大人时，但坦白说，我至今仍不觉得自己是个成熟的大人。所以你希望你未来的职业生涯会是怎样的？嗯，归根结底，我猜是一个临床（心理学）资质吧。但最终的目标是能够帮助人们，我猜无论最后具体从事什么工作，只要能总体上帮助到人们就好。太棒了。我觉得
that it's really exciting that you know that at this stage of your career because it really helps you to like supercharge the direction that you want to go in really whereas I only discovered or thought that I wanted to be a clinical psychologist pretty much during the last weeks of my undergraduate degree when I was already studying psychology so you know you've got this golden opportunity to really use this time as bonus time and I guess yeah like I know that our purpose of our podcast today is for you to ask me lots of questions um but in your position what I'd be doing is thinking about whether there's any work I could do even now at a level years that is about developing my ability to work with some of the core and key groups that clinical psychologists work with.
在你的职业生涯的这个阶段就知道这一点真的非常令人兴奋，因为这确实能帮你极大地激发你想要前进的方向。而我呢，基本上是在我的本科阶段的最后几周，当我已经在学习心理学的时候，才发现或觉得自己想成为一名临床心理学家。所以你看，你拥有这样一个绝佳的机会，可以真正把这段时间当作“额外的时间”来利用。而且我想，我明白我们今天播客的目的，是让你问我很多问题，但在你的位置上，我会思考，即使是在A-Level的这些年里，我是不是也可以做点什么工作，来发展我与临床心理学家所合作的核心与关键群体一起工作的能力。
So when I was your age, which sounds so patronising, and I'm sorry I just said it, I was working in boots at my weekends. But had I known I wanted to be a psychologist, then I might well have looked to work with adults or um you know children young people older adults I don't know like some sort of care role or something that allowed me to to get a really good head start on that so that I was you know hitting the ground running when I got to university I guess yeah so I worked with the with the vaccination program for COVID doing like sort of the behind the computer um stuff and that sort of helped me sort of get a more feel working for
所以当我像你这么大的时候——听起来好有居高临下的优教育感啊，抱歉我刚才这么说了——我周末是在Boots药妆店工作的。但如果我当时知道我想成为一名心理学家，我可能就会考虑去和成年人或者……你知道的，儿童、年轻人、老年人一起工作，做某种护理工作之类的事情，让我能够在这方面有一个非常好的领先起步，这样当我进入大学时，我就会……我猜，就能一马当先、迅速进入状态了。是的，所以我在新冠疫苗接种项目中工作过，做一些类似电脑后面的……之类的事情，这确实有助于让我对……获得更多作为付费员工与患者合作的实感，你知道的，还有与其他医疗专业人员，比如护士之类的合作，真的是很好的经验。
pay working with patients and you know um and other healthcare professionals like nurses and all sorts yeah really good experience yeah very good lovely so um yeah you have got some questions for me do you want to do you want to fire away yeah so first off i guess what's sort of your day-to-day like day in day out an average day for you what does that look like okay do you want the answer now that i'm in self-employment or do you want the answer as when i was an nhs psychologist or do you want the answer as when I was an NHS psychologist or do you want two answers? A bit of both, go on. A bit of both, okay so let's give me, I'll give you an idea of what my NHS role was like. So my most recent NHS role was working with working age adults in sort of community mental health team. Let me give you an idea, let me try and pick an average day. So I had what's called a job plan, which I had brought with me the kind of
是的，非常好，太棒了。所以，嗯，你确实给我准备了一些问题，你想现在就开始提问吗？好的，首先我想知道，你的日常生活是怎样的？日复一日，你平均的一天是什么样的？看起来是怎样的？好的，你是想要我现在作为一个自由职业者的答案，还是想要我作为NHS（英国国民保健制度）心理学家时的答案？或者你想要NHS心理学家的答案，还是两个都想要？两者都讲一点吧，来吧。两者都讲一点，好的，那我给你讲讲，我先给你讲讲我在NHS时的角色是怎样的。我最近的一份NHS工作是与工作年龄的成年人一起在一个社区心理健康团队中工作。让我给你描绘一个大概，让我试着挑一个平均的一天来讲。所以，我有一份所谓的“工作计划”，我是从我之前工作过的一个服务机构把这种工作计划的理念带过来的。所以我的周工作安排在内容上总是几乎完全一样的。
idea of a job plan from a previous service that I worked with. So my weeks always look pretty identical in terms of content. So it meant that I knew where my client bookings were going to be because I had to book the rooms in advance. So if I, for example, pick a Tuesday. So I was peripatetic, which means that I worked out a number of different bases. So I have one key base that I found myself. Yeah, when I was four days a week, I was actually in, I think, five different bases. So it was really frenetic. But I was really keen to be able to deliver the 50% face to face that the service wanted of that grade of staff. And people even told me it's not possible. It's not possible. You can't do it. And I was like, well, that's what I've been recruited to do. I'm gonna, I'm gonna blimmin well, go out there and do it. So my average Tuesday, when I was working most recently, I was using the outpatient department
这意味着我知道我的客户预约会在哪里，因为我必须提前预订房间。所以，如果我举个例子，选一个星期二。我是流动的（peripatetic），这意味着我在好几个不同的基地工作。我有一个自己所在的中心基地。是的，当我一周工作四天的时候，我实际上在——我想——五个不同的基地工作。所以节奏真的非常紧凑。但我非常渴望能够提供该级别员工所需的50%面对面服务。甚至有人对我说：“这不可能。这不可能。你做不到的。”而我说：“好吧，这就是我被招聘来做的工作。我偏要、偏要走出去把它做好。”所以在我最近工作时，我平均的星期二是在一家精神病院的门诊部度过的，我会把一天的时间分成不同的门诊时段。所以在星期二早上，例如，我会看三个客户。
of a psychiatric hospital and I would break my days down into clinics. So on a Tuesday morning, for example, I would see three clients. I would see a client at nine, a client at 10 and a client at 11, which meant that come 10 to 12, I just then had to write notes and then I was done and I could go and have some lunch and then head off to a different base. So those clients I was seeing, initially we were doing just, you know, waiting list clients. So people that I was seeing initially we were doing um just you know waiting list clients so people that I was doing interventions for um that come to the top of the waiting list for trauma predominantly um but um after a while I began to think we need a group in this service to try and teach some of the stuff that we'd usually do one-to-one so that it speeds up
我会在9点看一个客户，10点看一个，11点看一个。这意味着到了11点50分，我只需要写写病历记录，然后就完成了。接着我可以去吃个午餐，然后动身去另一个基地。我看的那些客户，最初我们只是在做……你知道的，等待名单上的客户。所以最初我接待的客户，我们只是在做……你知道的，等待名单上的客户，也就是那些我为其进行干预治疗的人……他们排到了等待名单的顶端，主要是针对创伤。但是，过了一段时间，我开始觉得，我们在这个服务机构里需要一个小组治疗，来尝试教授一些我们通常一对一做的事情，这样可以加快人们获得服务的速度。
people's access to the service and so you know often when you're in NHS or employed services groups take up a whole morning and I was like well that's not gonna help the waiting list that's going to make it worse in effect and so I said I want to use one of my existing client sessions but make that like a one-to-many model make it a group so do a whole group within an hour and so that's what I did before I left the service I'd done that twice so we'd done a pilot and then we'd done the whole group so it's what I did before I left the service I'd done that twice so we'd done a pilot and then we'd done the whole group so it's slightly shorter as a 50 minute session but actually in terms of the amount of information we were able to impart and the amount of people we were able to serve within that it was really useful and so you know I pride myself as thinking
所以，你知道，通常当你在NHS或受雇的服务机构中时，小组治疗会占去整个上午。而我认为，这帮不到等待名单，实际上会让情况变得更糟糕。所以我说，我想利用我现有的一个客户会话时间，把它改成“一对多”的模式，改成小组治疗。也就是在一个小时内进行整个小组的治疗。这就是我在离开该机构之前所做的事情。我已经做过两次了——我们做过一个试点，然后做了完整的小组。所以它稍微短一些，是一个50分钟的会话。但实际上，就我们能够传达的信息量以及在其中能够服务的人数而言，这真的非常有用。所以，你知道，我为自己能稍微跳出常规思考而感到自豪。然后在下午，
outside the box a little bit and then in the afternoon um on a Tuesday I think it was largely um admin time and supervision so supervision for myself which is obviously very important but also supervision for any um aspiring psychologists so either trainees or assistants or honorary assistants um also a bit of time to connect with the team as well in the shared office so hope was that a useful whistle stop tour of an nhs day ben yeah definitely yeah that's that's much more than i thought yeah i'm i'm quite productive yeah i'm productive have you got any questions or you, things that have been triggered for you when hearing that? I guess what are the different challenges of working with, you said working adults, but like different sorts of patients, I guess.
星期二的下午，我想主要是行政时间和督导时间。对我自己的督导——这显然非常重要，但同时也是对任何有志成为心理学家的人的督导——无论是实习生、助理还是荣誉助理。还有一点时间在共享办公室里与团队交流。所以，希望这是一个关于NHS一天的有用且快速的概述，本？是的，绝对是，是的。这比我想象的要多得多。是的，我很有效率。是的，很有成效。你有什么问题吗？或者听了这些，有没有触动到你、让你联想到什么？我想，与你说的成年人工作相比，与不同种类的患者一起工作，会有哪些不同的挑战呢？
Yeah, I mean, for me, one of the main challenges was that I was doing the bulk of the assessments. I love doing assessments. I find it a real privilege. I was doing the bulk of the assessments because they love doing assessments. I find it a real privilege. I was doing the bulk of the assessments because they were predictable and they're routine. People knew when to put those into my diary. So I would do an assessment on a Friday morning. And I think I'd also do an assessment on a Monday afternoon. It's a couple of years ago now, but Monday afternoon. And so there was two slots where people could book in for assessments but for me one of the main challenges was that I could really connect with people and could really see that they were in need of the service and more than that that they were going to be a good fit for what we had and we're going to respond well to our treatment. So I always used the assessment
是的，对我和我来说，主要的挑战之一是我承担了绝大多数的评估工作。我喜欢做评估。我发现这是一种真正的特权。我承担了绝大多数的评估工作，因为它们是可以预测的，而且是例行公事。人们知道什么时候把这些安排进我的日程表。所以我会在周五早上做一个评估。我想我周一下午也会做一个评估。这已经是几年前的事了，但大约是周一下午。所以当时有两个时间段人们可以预约评估。但对我来说，主要的挑战之一是，我能够真正与人们建立联系，并且能够清楚地看到他们确实需要这项服务，不仅如此，他们非常适合我们所提供的服务，并且会对我们的治疗做出良好的反应。所以我总是利用评估
sessions to kind of give a flavour of the work and to check that they were able to engage with it. And so for me, knowing that these people were there, they weren't just names on the list to me, they were people, they were people with stories and lives and loves and things that mattered and things that were hurting them. So for me, the biggest challenge was that people were having a wait for that service. And also that sometimes by the time people got to the top of the waiting list, they would disengage or there would be what we call DNA. So did not attend sessions. And it's just, yeah, it's tricky. But, you know know when you get when you pick up a client that just starts flying and does really well and um does come regularly um
会话来让对方对我们的工作有个大致的了解，并检查他们是否能够参与其中。对我来说，我知道这些人都在那里，对我和他们来说，他们不仅仅是名单上的名字，他们是人，是有故事、有生活、有爱、有在乎的事物以及正承受痛苦的事物的人。所以对我来说，最大的挑战是人们不得不排队等待这项服务。而且有时当人们排到等待名单的顶端时，他们会中途退出，或者出现我们所谓的“DNA”（Did Not Attend，即爽约/未出席）情况。这真是……是的，很棘手。但是，你知道，当你接诊到一个客户，他状态渐入佳境、做得非常好，而且能按时来……
you know it's just golden golden stuff it's a real privilege um yeah it's yeah um that sounds like something that i would be interested in like working with like one-to-one sort of with patients and uh like every week or every so often and sort of seeing that progression it was uh something that I'd like to do I think what's the work-life balance like sort of in the NHS I guess in the NHS um for me it was much better when I went part-time so I've got two children which you might well know if you listen to the podcast um you know when I was first qualified I was driving 25 miles each way um through sort of heavy traffic so before I had children you know I had to I worked nine till five and so I was out of the house um you know from 10 to 8 until 10 past six and that's that's a lot five days a week as well as obviously the exhaustion of if
你知道，这真的是无价之宝，是一种真正的特权。是的，这……这听起来像是我会感兴趣的事情，比如与患者进行一对一的工作，每周或定期进行，并看到那种进展。这确实是我想做的事情。NHS的工作生活平衡是怎样的，我猜在NHS里……对我来说，当我转为兼职时，情况好多了。我有两个孩子，如果你听过播客的话，你可能很清楚这一点。你知道，我刚取得资质时，我需要每天单程开车25英里，穿过……那种交通拥堵的路段。所以在我有孩子之前，你知道，我是从9点工作到5点，所以我离开家的时间是……你知道的，从8点10分到6点10分。一个星期五天都是这样，再加上如果遇到交通堵塞等情况带来的疲惫，那真的很多。但我一直非常喜欢午休。我总是会休息，总是花时间离开我的办公桌，并鼓励我的团队也和我一起这样做。所以这其实是一件非常非常美好、对我的工作生活平衡真正有帮助的事情。要么是步行去当地的商店或熟食店，要么是一起吃东西然后快速散步，或者只是坐在员工的公共区域聊天、建立联系……
there's traffic and stuff um but I've always been a real fan of lunch breaks I've always taken my break and always taken time to have that away from my desk and to encourage my team to do that with me and so that's something that's been really really lovely actually and really for me helps with the work-life balance so either strolling out to like the local shop or the local deli or eating together and then having a quick stroll or just sitting in sort of communal staff areas and just chatting and connecting and you know forming norming and you know storming in terms of what we do with teamwork um so yeah I think very fondly of my time in the NHS services that I've worked in but it is tricky you know there's a big job um and you know I think we need to make sure that we've got stuff going on outside of work that
在团队合作方面经历“形成、规范、风暴”（forming, norming, storming）的过程。所以，是的，我对我在NHS工作过的服务机构的时光有着非常美好的回忆。但这也确实很棘手，你知道的，这是一项繁重的工作。而且你知道，我认为我们需要确保我们在工作之外也有自己的生活，不能让工作成为我们生活的全部。这很棘手，因为你知道……我完全认为自己就是玛丽安，但我的部分身份认同是我是一名心理学家。所以当我刚认识我丈夫时，他问我：“你为什么不多做点别的？你为什么没有更多的好大喜功的爱好？”而我说：“我不知道，我只是觉得挺满足的，你知道的，我和朋友们在一起，这就足够了，因为我的工作已经让我感到很满足了。”所以，你知道，这听起来可能有点奇怪，但对我来说就是这样的。是的，我想如果你喜欢你做的事情，那就很值得。至于我在私人执业中所做的事情。所以我很大程度上保留了诊所的模式。
this isn't all we do it's tricky because you know um I absolutely think of myself as as being Marianne but part of my identity is that I'm a psychologist and so when I first met my husband he was like why don't you do more why why haven't you got more hobbies and I was like I don't know I'm just kind of fulfilled like you know I spend time with my friends and that's enough for me because I'm already fulfilled by my work. So, you know, that might sound a bit weird, but that's how it is for me. Yeah, I suppose if you enjoy what you do, it's not worth it. In terms of what I do in private practice. So I very much kept the clinic model.
所以我会在周二、周三和周四的上午接待三位客户，我想保持这种状态。我想把规模维持在这个水平。这往往就是我一整周接待的所有客户了。所以，是的，我在午饭前就完成了工作，但下午我会用来为媒体写作、编辑播客，或者致力于书籍、课程和项目。所以我绝对不是坐在那里闲得无聊。而在周一和周五，我现在的自雇工作生活平衡明显更好了。所以周一对我来说往往是一个比较安静的日子，我可以处理一些行政工作和零星杂务。周五早上，我通常会在周五早上做播客，我也会去进行私人健身训练。但，是的，我确实做媒体辅导，而且……是的，我其实很热爱我的生活。所以，总会有……你知道的，杂志社邀请我写的文章，或者是我自己投稿的……
So I do on a Tuesday, Wednesday and Thursday morning, I see three clients and I wanted to keep it. I want to keep it at that. So that that tends to be as many clients as I see in a whole week. So, yeah, I'm done by lunchtime, but I use the afternoons to write for the media or to edit podcasts or to to work on books and courses and projects so I'm definitely not sitting around twiddling my thumbs and on a Monday and a Friday so I've definitely got better work-life balance now that I'm self-employed so on a Monday tends to be a bit of a quieter day for me where I can get through some of the admin the bits and pieces um on a Friday morning I tend to do podcasts on a on a Friday morning I also go out to personal training as well um but yeah I I do media coaching and um yeah I just I love my life actually um so yeah there's uh there's always you know articles I'm being asked to write or that I pitch
所以，是的，我让自己非常忙碌，并努力使我的工作组合多样化，这样我就不会在任何特定领域精疲力竭或压力过大。是的，嗯，你觉得成为一名临床心理学家的核心技能是什么？在进入这个领域之前，我现在应该培养什么样的技能？是的，好问题。这些可能都是相当难以衡量的技能。但我认为，是那种能够产生同理心、能够为他人的痛苦所触动，但又不会让自己陷入恐慌或卷入混乱之中的能力。不过，听起来真的很傻。为什么这是我脑子里冒出的第一个
for um so yeah I keep myself very busy and try and diversify my portfolio so I'm being asked to write or that I pitch for um so yeah I keep myself very busy and try and diversify my portfolio so I'm not getting burned out or kind of yeah strung out in any particular area yeah um what would you say the key skills to do sort of a job like being a clinical psychologist what sort of skills should I be developing now before I get to? Yeah, good question. Probably they're ones that are pretty tricky to measure, really. But I think it's the ability to have empathy, to be moved by the distress of others, but not in such a way that you're panicking or you're kind of brought into the chaos as well. But, you know, sounds really silly. Why is this the first thing that
想法？但在我成为心理学家的很久很久以前，我就在阅读诸如《That's Life》之类的杂志，你可能都没听说过。但我真的很喜欢那种每周出版、包含真人真事案例研究的杂志。就像我刚才说的，现在想来确实有点傻。但它给了我一个非常有用的第一手直觉——当然，正如杂志文章所能做到的那样——让我对真实的人的内心想法和感受，以及各种……嗯……各种事件和情况有了第一手直觉。所以，我第一次阅读或了解到有人在童年时期曾遭受性虐待，就是通过那种杂志。所以我觉得这在同理心方面，以及在临床心理学中我们需要具备一定知识或经验的广泛事物方面，给了我一个非常有用的领先起步。所以，当然，这没关系。我经常……你知道的，我会对客户说：“真的很抱歉，我以前没听说过这个，你能跟我讲讲吗？这对你来说是什么样的？”
comes to me? But long before I was a psychologist, I was reading magazines like That's Life, which you might not have even heard of. But I really liked those kind of weekly magazines that have got human interest case studies in. And like I said, it does sound pretty silly now I think about it. But it gave me a really useful firsthand insight firsthand as much as magazine articles can, but a firsthand insight into the kind of inner thoughts and feelings of real people and to a variety of um yeah presentations and things that happened so the first time I'd read or been aware of people who'd um been sexually abused as children was via that sort of magazine. And so I felt like that gave me a really useful head start in terms of empathy and in terms of the wide array of things
但是，你知道，如果你曾与特定情况的患者工作过，或者如果你对这方面有所了解，确实会有所帮助，因为我认为人们会感到更安心一些。你知道的，他们会觉得你理解他们的处境，所以他们觉得自己被看到、被听到、被认可了，我想也得到了赋能，他们也会充满希望。所以这可能是一个糟糕的回答，你知道的，“去你的超市买几本杂志吧”，但是，你知道，只要试着去理解你未来的客户可能正在挣扎的一些想法。我不知道，这可能是一个非常糟糕的回答，本。这其实挺自然地切入我的下一个问题，真的……你觉得我应该阅读哪些书？以及阅读什么类型的书之类的？
that we need to have some knowledge or experience of in clinical psychology. So absolutely it doesn't matter. i often some you know i will say to clients i'm really sorry i've not heard of that before could you tell me a bit about that and what that's like for you um but you know it does does help if you've either worked with people in a specific um presentation or if you've got some knowledge of that because I think people do feel a bit more at ease you know like you understand their position and so they feel seen and heard and validated and I guess empowered they're hopeful as well so that's probably a rubbish answer you know go to your supermarket buy some magazines but you know just try to get on board with some of the ideas that your future
是的……嗯，所以如果我不提《有志心理学家合集》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）和《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），那就是我的失职了。当然，这些是任何有志成为心理学家的人的必读之书。但我会广泛阅读各种书籍，包括自传。我最近非常喜欢……米歇尔·奥巴马（Michelle Obama）的自传。她在书中谈到了……她真正反思了她的交叉性（intersectionality），以及在遇到她丈夫之前，她是如何能够取得她所取得的成就的……以及他们取得了多么伟大的成就，但对她来说，始终保持……
clients might be struggling with i don't that might be a really rubbish answer then it sort of falls into my next question quite nice actually um what books would you recommend i sort of be reading and sort of types of types of books and stuff like that yeah um so I'd be remiss of me not to say the aspiring psychologist collective and the clinical psychologist collective of course those are must reads for any aspiring psychologist um but I would read a wide array of books including autobiographies so I recently really enjoyed um Michelle Obama's autobiography um where she talks about kind of she really reflects on her intersectionality and how she was able to achieve the things that she achieved even before she met um her husband um and you know what greatness they achieved but how it was
与她想要实现的独特目标建立联系是多么重要。她希望，特别是年轻人，在他们离开白宫时能处于比刚进去时更好的状态。所以，是的，就是广泛地阅读，真的。还有提出问题，阅读那些能为你引发对话的书籍。所以我真的非常喜欢亚龙（Yalom）、欧文·亚龙（Irvin Yalom，拼写：I-R-V-I-N, Y-A-L-O-M）的作品。他的书中，我最喜欢的一本是《爱情刽子手》（Love's Executioner）。在这本书中，他非常诚实地讲述了他曾合作过的一些不同的客户以及他们所走过的旅程，同时也分享了他自己作为他们的治疗师的个人反思。他的另一本非常好的书叫《凝视太阳》（Staring at the Sun）。这本书讲的全是关于死亡焦虑的人，以及与……甚至不一定是……
really important for her to you know to connect to unique things that she wanted to achieve and she wanted you know youth specifically to be in a better position when they left office than when they entered it. And so, yeah, just reading, reading widely, really. And yeah, asking questions, reading things that, that evoke conversations for you. So I really, really like the works of Yalom, Irvin Yalom, I-R-V-I-N, Yalom, Y-A-L-O-M. So his, but my favourite book of his is Love's Executioner. And within that, he's very honest, as he talks about his different, some of his different clients that he's worked with and the journeys they've made, but also his own kind of personal reflections on what it's like to be their therapist. Another really nice book by him, which is called Staring at the Sun. And that's all about people with death anxiety and working with not even
所有老年人工作，而是与那些由于某种原因在思考自己终有一死的人工作。我真的很喜欢他的写作风格。所以，是的，对于任何处于心理学职业生涯任何阶段的人，尤其是像你目前这个阶段的人，我认为这是一本你可以用现有的理解去阅读的书，但随着你职业生涯的推进，再次翻开它，重新阅读它，因为一旦你有了不同的思考、经验和反思可以汲取，你将以不同的方式从中获得更多收获。是的，是的，听起来不错，我会去读读看的。所以我的下一个问题是，通过NHS晋升的机会有哪些？你可能不太了解……我现在已经转向私人执业了，但如果沿着NHS的阶梯往上走的话……
necessarily all older adults, but people that are considering for whatever reason their own mortality. And I just really like his style of writing. So yeah, for anyone who's probably at any stage of their psychology career, but certainly at the stage that you're at, I think it's a sort of book that you can read now with the understanding that you've got now but as you progress through your career pick it up again and you know read it again because you'll you'll get more in a different way from it once you've got different thoughts experiences and reflections to draw upon yeah yeah that sounds i'll give that a look um so my next question would be what sort of opportunities are there for progression like through the nhs you might not know i've been
是的，好问题。所以，嗯……在我开始接受培训之前，我是一名Band 4的助理心理学家，然后我进入了培训，那是一个Band 6的实习临床心理学家职位，然后你在Band 7获得资质。实际上，我离开了我的Band 7职位，尽管我非常热爱它。而且尽管我和一些一起工作过的人几乎每天都保持着联系——好吧，我们有一个WhatsApp群，你知道的，他们真是太可爱了，简直就是我的同道中人。但他们在当时没有任何晋升职位空缺。所以当我获得资质时，我们刚从……实际上，当我获得资质时，周围没有什么合格的工作岗位，因为我不知道你对……你知道的，25年代中期（应为千禧年代中期）的金融文化了解多少。但在2008年，由于按揭贷款等原因发生了一场大崩盘，还有Northern Rock银行以及诸如此类的事情。
like private nowadays but going like through up the nhs ladder i guess yeah good question so um i before i started training i was a band four assistant psychologist and then i got on to training which was um a band six trainee clinical psychologist role and then you qualify at band seven i actually left my band seven post, even though I adored it. And even though I'm still in contact with some of the people I worked with on an almost daily basis. Well, we've got a WhatsApp group and, you know, they were just lovely, you know, just my tribe. But they didn't have any at that time. They didn't have any progression roles available. And so when I qualified, we were quite fresh out of. So actually, when I qualified, there were no qualified jobs around because I don't know how much you know about, you know, mid-naughties financial culture. But in 2008, there was a big crash due to mortgages and things
这意味着在我2011年毕业时发生了一次经济衰退。当时字面上……在我们毕业的时候，我那一届16个人里面只有2个人找到了工作。所以当时根本没有多少资金，我想对博士培训名额的资金投入也会被削减。所以在我们结束时，我那一届招收新学员的名额已经缩减到了10人，而在培训期间我们是15个人中的一个。然后我想第二年他们把名额增加到了17人，接着我想可能又稍微增加了一点，但到我完成时，新招生的名额又悄悄降到了10人，这要少得多。所以当时对心理健康的重要性及其资金投入并没有那种程度的关注，这真的很不幸。而且我不认为未来如果再发生经济衰退，同样的事情会再次发生。有些人说，嗯，上个季度经济有一点增长，所以从技术上讲，这意味着我们不可能处于衰退中。但是，你知道，
and Northern Rock and all of that jazz. And it meant that there was a recession when I graduated 2011. And there were literally, you know, by the time we graduated, there was only two out of 16 of us on my cohort who had jobs. And so there just there wasn't much funding, I think there would be cuts made to funding places for training for the doctorate as well. So by the time I finished, I think my cohort had been reduced to 10 for new people coming on for my course whereas during training I was 15 one of 15 and then I think the following year they'd increased it to 17 and then I think it
我认为我们仍然认为某种程度的经济衰退是有可能的，尤其是伴随着生活成本危机。所以我希望心理健康资金不会被削减，实际上这次情况会正好相反。是的，我忘了你的问题了，我回答了吗？我甚至都不记得了。是的，是的……你觉得晋升的机会——也许不是晋升，我不知道——哦，对了，让我回到那部分问题上来。所以，嗯，我离开了原来那个Band 7的职位，因为尽管他们喜欢我和我的工作，我也喜欢他们和那里的工作，但当时并没有那种晋升的机会。所以我转到了一个Band 8a的职位，实际上离家更近了，所以也并非全无坏事。我在那里学到了很多很多东西，也结下了美好的情谊。但当考虑到Band 8b时，确实有这样的机会，我也曾接受过Band 8b的面试。但在当时——我想他们后来改了规则——在当时，如果你……即使你是兼职，当你晋升到一个更高的职级时，你必须支付全额的养老金
might have gone up slightly again but by the time I finished it crept down for the new uptake to 10 which is a lot smaller so there just wasn't that level of focus on the importance of mental health and funding it, which is really unfortunate, actually. And I don't think the same thing will happen again, you know, with any future recession. Some people are saying, well, there's been a bit of growth in the economy in the last quarter. So that means technically, we can't be in recession. But, you you know I think we're still thinking that some element of recession is likely especially with the cost of living crisis and so I would hope that there won't be cuts in mental health funding and actually the opposite would be true this time
缴费，尽管我只是兼职。所以实际上，我承担了更多的责任，收入反而会变少。所以对我不来说，这并不是我真正想做的事。我不想为了更少的钱去做更辛苦的工作。虽然这并不完全是为了钱，但你知道，有钱确实能让生活中的事情更容易安排一些。所以确实有晋升的机会。而且，你知道，我有朋友在做Band 8b的职位。我不知道我是不是已经有了在做……我想我确实有一个朋友在做Band 8c的职位，但她换了岗位，而且我想在某个时候又降回了Band 8b。所以晋升是有的，但说实话，这并不是我特别热衷的事情。是的，这很合理。我热爱与客户的直接工作，你看，你越往上走，你需要做的客户工作就越少，而我太喜欢它了。你觉得——显然现在转向私人执业了——你与客户工作的体验有多大不同？
yeah I've forgotten your question did I did I answer it I can't even remember yeah yeah um what sort of what do you think the progression maybe not progression I don't know oh yeah it was let me come let me come back to that bit of question then so um I left the um the band seven position I was in because as much as they loved me and my work and I loved them and the work there wasn't that there wasn't that progression opportunity at that time and so I moved on to an 8a um which was actually closer to homes it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't all bad at all and I learned many many things and made lovely connections there too um but when it came to thinking about 8B, there were opportunities and I had been interviewed for 8B opportunities. But at the time, I think they've changed it since at the time, if you, even if you're part time, when you did a band above, you had to pay full pension
所以，确实有不同。我要说，最大的相似之处在于由医疗保险资助的工作——这最像是NHS的工作。我的意思是，那些为员工资助医疗保健的机构工作的人。英国有很多大型雇主，你可能甚至没有意识到他们为员工资助了健康保险。我想这部分工作感觉最像NHS。你会遇到那些非常积极的客户，特别是如果他们是自费的话。是的，这很不同。这很不同，但他们依然是人，你知道的，我们都是在各种经历中长大的，这些经历并不完美，并给我们留下了关于自己的看法。这依然关乎传播同情心和自我同情心的价值与重要性：对他人慈悲，对自己慈悲。
contributions, even though I was only part time. And so I actually would have been worse off for more responsibility. So for me, that was that wasn't really what I wanted to be doing. I didn't want to work harder for less money. And whilst it isn't all about the money, you know, it sure does help make things a bit easier to organise in your life um so there are progression opportunities and um you know I've got friends working in 8b roles um I don't know if I've yet got anyone working I think I did have a friend working in 8c but she moved roles um and I think went back down to 8b at some point so there is progression um but it's not really something that I was that passionate about to be honest yeah that's fair enough um I love client work
并且，是的，看看我能做些什么来帮助人们度过悲伤、抑郁和创伤。所以我的工作并没有发生巨大的改变，只是我省去了所有的官僚作风，省去了无数次“为了开会而开会”的会议。所以我能够脚踏实地，在人们真正需要的时候帮助他们，与在等待名单上等上好几年相比，这感觉像是一种真正的奢侈。是的，是的，这……这完美地回答了我的问题，我想。那么，在我目前所处的位置和最终取得资质之间的这段时间里，你觉得心理健康领域的系统会有所改变吗？显然这是一个不断发展的领域，在媒体上受到越来越多的关注，还有……所以你觉得它会成为一个不同的行业吗？
you see and the further and further up you go the less and less client work you tend to do and I love it um what do you think so obviously now going private is it is how much different is your experience like working with clients? So it is different I'd say the most similarities are health insurance funded work so that's when it most feels like the NHS work. And by that, I mean, people that work for organisations that fund healthcare for their employees. So there's a number of large employees in the UK that you might not even realise fund health cover for their employees. And I'd say that's the work that most feel similar to the nhs um you get people that are really motivated especially if they're self-funding um yeah it's
好问题。所以，嗯，有一种趋势是——心理学家，尤其是临床心理学家，经常被人力资源（HR）和其他部门视为一种昂贵的资源。但是，我认为，一旦人们与临床心理学家和其他专业合格的心理学家合作过，他们就会看到其中的价值。他们会看到这对团队的价值，也会看到这对我们服务的客户的价值。但这并不总是以与委员会相同的方式被看待。委员会会觉得：“好吧，我们可以用一个Band 8b心理学家的钱（如果8b处于薪级顶端的话），雇佣三个、甚至四个Band 6的员工。”你知道的，当然，如果Band 8b处于顶端的话。但是，你知道，我认为曾经有一个阶段，确实有一种趋势是……
it's different it's different but still humans you know and we've still all been raised in ways that give us experiences that are not ideal and give us ideas about ourselves and it's still about spreading the value and importance of compassion and self-compassion to compassion to others compassion to self um and yeah seeing what i can do to help people work through grief depression and trauma so you know my work hasn't changed massively it's just that I've cut out all the levels of bureaucracy and all the meetings about meetings about meetings and so I'm able to get my feet on the ground and help people at the point that they need it which feels like a real luxury compared to a couple of years wait on a waiting list yeah yeah that's yeah that's my question perfectly i think um so in between the
转向更少培训和更少经验的员工。但我希望专业合格的心理学家永远有一席之地，因为我看到了真正的价值。所以，你目前处于……我猜你现在大概16或17岁。我是6月出生的“宝宝”。所以在你这个年纪我16岁，直到27岁我才开始我的资质和培训。我30岁毕业。所以，你知道，你可能还有14年左右的时间——你可能会比我更快达到目标，我当时还去环游世界了。所以我确实也鼓励你这么做。但你可能会比我更快到达。14年后的心理健康服务会是什么样的？我不知道。我真的、真的很希望并祈祷到那时仍然会有NHS。所以，尽管我不在NHS工作，但我一直是它的热忱支持者。并且我坚信人们应该在医疗服务交付的那个点上获得免费医疗。所以我真的希望到那时依然有一个NHS，让你能在其中工作，并为那些需要服务的客户服务，本。
sort of point where i am now and getting qualified do you think the system will have changed with mental health obviously it's a growing growing fields more more attention in the media and there's that so do you think it will will be a different sort of profession good question so um there is a move towards you know psychologists especially clinical ones are often regarded as an expensive resource by um by hr and other departments um uh but what i think once people have worked with clinical psychologists and other professionally qualified psychologists as well um they see the value of that they see the value of that for teams and they see the value of that for the clients that we serve. But that's not always necessarily seen in the same way as commissioners who are like, well, we could get these band six members of staff, we could get three of those for the price of, you know,
是的，是的，我同意。我想这就是我所有的全部问题了，除非你还有什么想说的。我想我已经……你完美地回答了所有问题。
we could get four of those for the price of an 8B psychologist, you know, if the 8B is at the top of their tree. But, you know, I think there was certainly at one stage a move towards um yeah less trained and less experienced staff um but i hope there will always be a role for professionally qualified psychologists um because I see there's a real value so you know so you are in you know you're I guess you're probably 16 or 17 currently I was I was a young baby so I was a June baby so in your position I was 16 um and I didn't start my qualification and start my training until I was 27. And I graduated age 30. So, you know, you've got perhaps 14 ish years, you'll probably get there quicker than me. I went off traveling around
我们可以用一个8B心理学家的价格买四个那种，你知道的，如果那个8B处于他们领域的顶端的话。但是，你知道，我认为在某个阶段确实有一种趋势，就是转向嗯，是的，培训较少、经验较少的员工，嗯，但我希望专业资质的心理学家永远有一席之地，嗯，因为我看到了真正的价值，所以你知道，所以你现在，嗯，我猜你现在大概16或17岁，我以前是个小婴儿，我是6月出生的婴儿，所以在你的位置上我16岁，嗯，我直到27岁才开始我的资质认证和培训。我30岁毕业。所以，你知道，你大概还有14年左右的时间，你可能会比我更快到达那里。我也去周游了
the world as well. So I do encourage you to do that too. But you'll probably get there quicker than me. What will mental health services be like in 14 years? I don't know. I really, really hope and pray that there will still be an NHS. So even though I don't work in the NHS, I'm a passionate supporter of it. And I really believe in people having access to free health care at the point of delivery. So I would really hope there's still an NHS for you to work in and for clients to to serve Ben yeah yeah I agree um I think that's sort of all the questions I've got unless you've got anything else you'd like to say I think I'm you've answered everything uh amazingly
世界。所以我也鼓励你这么做。但你可能会比我更快到达那里。14年后的心理健康服务会是什么样的？我不知道。我真的、真的很希望并祈祷仍然会有NHS（国民医疗服务体系）。所以即使我不为NHS工作，我也是它的热心支持者。我坚信人们应该在获得医疗服务的节点上获得免费医疗。所以我真的很希望仍然有一个NHS供你工作，为客户服务，本，是的，是的，我同意，嗯，我想这就是我所有的全部问题了，除非你还有什么想说的，我想你已经把所有问题都回答得太棒了
oh thanks Ben um no I think yeah I think we've covered it we've covered a lot of ground but um how has it been interviewing me what's it been like for you yeah it's been good yeah definitely different to anything i've had before so yeah i having good experience yeah I was meaning to drum up some other questions as well and I will level with you all dear listeners that I had a diary malfunction this morning and Ben very set very politely sent me a message saying ready when you are and I was like oh man I was I hadn't done I hadn't even sent you a link to access recording and I was I followed you on socials like I said I would and then I was supposed to drum up some um some other questions and I'm so sorry busy week busy minds um but yeah you did really well with the questions um that you
哦谢谢本，嗯不，我想是的，我觉得我们已经讨论得很全面了，聊了很多内容，但是嗯，采访我感觉怎么样？对你来说是什么体验？是的，挺好的，确实跟我以前经历过的任何事情都不同，所以这是一次很好的体验。我本来还想准备一些其他问题，各位亲爱的听众朋友，我也跟你们坦白，我今天早上日程安排出了点小状况，本非常客气地给我发了一条消息说“随时准备好”，然后我就想，天哪，我甚至都还没发给你录音链接呢，不过我确实像说过的那样在社交媒体上关注了你，然后我本来应该准备一些其他问题的，非常抱歉，这周太忙，脑子也转不过弯来……不过，你带给我的那些问题真的准备得很好，所以再次感谢你抽出时间。我们刚才的网络有点小故障，所以本没有开摄像头，但我们会配上一张精美的照片，这样你们就能看到他的脸了。是的，非常感谢你的热情和好奇心，祝你的A-Level考试一切顺利，考完后一定要告诉我情况，如果以后需要任何支持或指导，也请随时联系我。谢谢，真的谢谢。能在这个阶段与本交流真的是一种荣幸，我也很期待看到他的职业生涯将如何发展和展开。如果你对播客节目有什么好的想法，觉得会对大家有帮助，请务必与我联系。你可以通过我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast 上的联系表单找到我。希望你觉得这一期节目对你有帮助。如果你希望获得任何
brought to me so thank you again um for your time um we had a little bit of a wi-fi um hiccup which is why ben's not on um not on camera but we're going to get a lovely picture so you'll be able to see his face um yes but thank you so much for your enthusiasm your intrigue wishing you the very best with your a levels um do let me know how you get on um and if you need any support or guidance in future thank you yeah thank you honestly what a privilege to chat with ben at this stage of his career and i'm looking forward to to seeing how his career develops and unfolds if you've got any ideas for podcast episodes that you think would be useful, do please get in contact with me. You can fill in my contact form at www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast. I hope you found this session useful. And if you would welcome any
额外的支持，请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership）、阅读《有抱负的心理学家合集》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective book）以及《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective book）。好的，我很期待在我们的下一期播客节目中与大家相聚，节目将于周一早上6点准时上线。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我们很快就会再见。保重。并且已经取得了资格，有那么多的技巧和经验可以学习，有那么多的方法可以尝试，“有抱负的
additional support, do consider the aspiring psychologist membership the aspiring psychologist collective book and the clinical psychologist collective book too right i will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode of the podcast which will be coming to you from 6 a.m on monday, thank you so much for being part of my world, and I'll catch up with you very soon. Take care. and qualified so many tips and lessons to learn from so many things that you can try the aspiring
心理学家合集”，“有抱负的心理学家合集”，心理学家合集。我叫亚娜（Jana），是一名见习心理福祉从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我觉得里面所有的不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。通往这个职业的途径竟然有这么多，这让我感到很惊讶，而且成为
psychologist collective the aspiring psychologist collective Psychologist Collective My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become
临床心理学家并没有一条完美的必经之路。这给了我很大的信心，让我觉得“不，我没有走错路”，从而减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些忐忑，我绝对推荐你读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，只要你翻开这本书，就绝对舍不得放下来。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一个，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，并且减轻了我的自我压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这个，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的，但相信我，一旦你开始，你就不会放下这本书。这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。